♫ I think I'm ready to do my thing ♫
♫ I think I'm ready to take my chances ♫
♫ I've been dining out and all stressed out ♫
♫ Due to the circumstances. See? ♫
♫ I gotta get up, get up, get up, get up ♫
♫ Wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up ♫
♫ I see what you're saying ♫
♫ We sent a demo to the world, they said it sounds like Take 6 ♫
♫ I said "Hold on, wait a minute, I'll be back with the remix" ♫
♫ They looking at us funny, we can't make any money ♫
♫ It took us years to figure out that we was dealing with dummies ♫
♫ They didn't understand the sound from the Bronx, that's the boogie down ♫
♫ to Huntsville, Alabama, there's no circles in my planner, so ♫
♫ It was time to make the product, so we hooked up with Townsend ♫
♫ Made a deal with John Neal, on the road sold ten thousand ♫
♫ WBA, that means a trip to Nashville ♫
♫ Festplatte showed up and said them boys are naturals ♫
♫ Can you hear what they were hearing? See what they were seeing? ♫
♫ From Bronx to Berlin, we took the tour European ♫
♫ All vocal yeah, we widit, call the album "What is it?" ♫
♫ With Sarah Connor, set the goal for number one and we hit it ♫
♫ But now it's Kev, Sim, Drew, Stew, time for a new day ♫
♫ Ring the alarm, hit 'em on Skype or a two-way ♫
♫ Sung by the words, we ready to fly! ♫
♫ Fly baby! Time to leave that nest ♫
♫ Fly baby! This ain't no time to rest ♫
♫ Come on fly baby, we got work to do ♫
♫ Here we go, spread my wings and ... ♫
♫ Fly baby! Time to leave that nest ♫
♫ Fly baby! This ain't no time to rest. Come on ♫
♫ Fly baby! We got work to do ♫
♫ Here we go. Spread my wings and fly. One more time ♫
♫ Fly baby! Time to leave that nest ♫
♫ Fly baby! This ain't no time to rest ♫
♫ Fly baby! We got work to do ♫
♫ Here we go, spread my wings and ... ♫
♫ Fly baby! Fly baby fly ♫
♫ Fly baby! Fly baby high ♫
♫ Fly baby! Up to the sky ♫
♫ Spread my wings and fly ♫
Instrumental!
♫ We're ready to fly! ♫
(Applause)
Thank you very much.